this is the most dangerous problem in
mathematics one that young
mathematicians are warned not to waste
their time on it's a simple conjecture
that not even the world's best
mathematicians have been able to solve
paul erdosh a famous mathematician said
mathematics is not yet ripe enough for
such questions
here's how it works pick a number any
number
seven
good choice
okay we're going to apply two rules if
the number is odd we multiply by three
and add one so three times seven is
twenty-one plus one is twenty-two
if the number is even we divide by two
so twenty-two divided by two is eleven
now we keep applying these two rules 11
is odd so we multiply by 3 33 and add
one 34
even divide by 2 17
odd multiply by 3 51 add 1 52 even
divide by 2 26 still even divide by 2 13
odd so we multiply by 3 39 add 1 and
that's 40 which is even so we divide by
2 20 divide by 2 10 divided by 2 5
odd multiply by 3 15 add 1 16 divide by
2 that's 8 and then 4 2 and 1.
now 1 is odd so we multiply by 3 and add
1 which equals four but four goes to two
goes to one
so we're in a loop and the lowest number
is one
now the conjecture is this
every positive integer if you apply
these rules will eventually end up in
the 4-2-1 loop
this is commonly called the collats
conjecture after german mathematician
lother collats who may have come up with
it in the 1930s but the problem has many
origin stories and many names it's also
known as the ulam conjecture kakutani's
problem the weights conjecture hass's
algorithm the syracuse problem and
simply 3n plus 1. why is 3x plus 1 so
famous among professional mathematicians
maybe it's not famous but infamous
in the sense that if someone actually
admits
in public that they're working on it
then there's something wrong with them
the numbers you get by applying 3x 1 are
called hailstone numbers because they go
up and down like hailstones in a
thundercloud but eventually they all
fall down to one or at least we think
they do
you can think of the numbers as
representing the height above the ground
in meters so a number like 26 would
start 26 meters above the ground and if
you apply 3x plus 1 it rises up as high
as 40 meters and in total it takes 10
steps to get to 1. so 10 is called its
total stopping time but take the very
next number 27 and it bounces around all
over the place
in fact it climbs all the way up to 9232
as an altitude that is higher than mount
everest
before it too
falls back to the ground
in total it takes 111 steps for 27 to
get down to 1 and end up in the 4-2-1
loop
the path that different numbers take
vary so widely even numbers right next
to each other
so how do you even start to make
progress on this problem
well honestly mathematicians struggled
people just decided this was something
invented by the soviets to slow down
u.s science
and it was doing a good job at it
because everybody's sitting there
twiddling their thumbs and making no
progress on this trivial
thing that you can tell school children
jeffrey legarius is the world authority
on 3x plus one the first time i met him
i was a senior in college and he pulled
me aside and he said
don't do this
don't work on this problem if you want
to have a career
do not start spending time
writing
about this or publishing any papers
about this
do real math for a while to establish
yourself
alex conterovich didn't listen
he and yakov sinai looked at the paths
of the hailstone numbers were there any
patterns well obviously all of them end
up at one but what about the paths they
take to get there
the pattern is randomness
here is the sequence of a large number
chosen at random the graph peaks and
then drops solo that you can't really
see what's happening at this scale
but if you take the logarithm you find
this wiggly graph with a downward trend
it looks kind of like the stock market
on a bad day
and this is no coincidence both are
examples of geometric brownian motion
that means if you take the log and
remove the linear trend the fluctuations
are random it's like flipping a coin
each step if the coin is heads the line
goes up tails it goes down three x plus
one is just like the random wiggles of
the stock market over long enough
periods the stock market tends to trend
upwards while three x plus one trends
down
another way to analyze three x plus one
is by looking at the leading digit of
each number in a sequence
here are the hailstone numbers starting
with three as the seed and we can count
up how many numbers start with a one how
many start with a two how many start
with a three and so on to make a
histogram
we can do the same thing for the
sequence that starts with four that's a
short one
and for the sequences that start with
five
six and seven again for each sequence
we're just counting up how many numbers
start with each digit one through nine
and adding that to our histogram
if you keep doing this for more and more
numbers eventually the histogram settles
into a stable pattern
for the first billion sequences you'll
find one is by far the most common
leading digit thirty percent of all
numbers start with one around seventeen
and a half percent start with two twelve
percent start with three and the
frequency decreases for higher digits
fewer than five percent of all the
numbers start with nine
now this pattern is not unique to three
x plus one it actually comes up
everywhere from the populations of
countries to the value of companies all
the physical constants and the fibonacci
numbers just to name a few
the distribution is known as benford's
law and it is even used to detect fraud
if all the numbers on your income tax
forms obey benford's law then well
you're probably being honest if not you
may be hiding something in elections
benford's law can be used to spot
irregularities though you have to apply
it correctly benford's law works best
when the numbers involved span several
orders of magnitude as they do for three
x plus one
but benford's law can't tell us whether
all numbers will end up in the 4-2-1
loop or not
for that we need a different sort of
analysis
at first glance it seems strange that
when you apply 3x plus 1 all numbers
should end up at 1.
i mean consider that there are the same
number of odd and even numbers but odd
numbers are more than tripled while even
numbers are only cut in half
therefore it seems like every sequence
on average should grow not shrink
but here's the catch every time you
multiply an odd number by three and then
add one it will always become an even
number and that means the next step is
to divide by two
so odd numbers are not actually tripled
by three x plus one they're increased by
a factor of about three over two i'm
neglecting the plus one because it's
insignificant for large numbers
and three halves is actually the most an
odd number can grow in one step
think of the path from one odd number in
a sequence to the next odd number after
multiplying by three and adding one you
have an even number and fifty percent of
the time dividing by two brings you back
to an odd number
but a quarter of the time you can divide
by four before you get to the next odd
number so for a quarter of numbers the
next one in the sequence will be
three-fourths of its initial value
an eighth of the time you can divide by
eight before getting to the next odd
number and a sixteenth of the time you
can divide by 16 and so on
if you take the geometric mean you find
on average to get from one odd number to
the next one you multiply by three over
four which is less than one so
statistically speaking three x plus one
sequences are more likely to shrink than
grow
take 341 for example multiply by three
and add one you get 1024
which you can divide by two and then
divide by two again and again and again
and again ten times in total until
you're down to one
one way to visualize these paths of
numbers in three x plus one is simply to
show how each number connects to the
next one in its sequence this is called
a directed graph
it looks like a tree or a series of
little streams that flow into each other
if the conjecture is true it means that
every single number is connected to this
graph every tiny stream all the way out
to infinity eventually flows into the
massive river of 4 2 1.
some mathematicians have modified this
visualization by rotating the graph at
each number anti-clockwise if it's an
odd number and clockwise if it's even
and then you end up with a structure
that looks like a coral or seaweed
and by adjusting the degree of rotation
for odd and even numbers you can create
these beautiful organic looking shapes
now there are two ways the conjecture
could be false there could be a number
somewhere some seed that starts a
sequence of numbers that grows to
infinity
for whatever reason it doesn't obey the
same numerical gravity as all of the
other numbers another possibility is
there exists a sequence of numbers that
forms a closed loop
all the numbers in this loop would be
unconnected to the main graph
but thus far no loop or sequence that
shoots off to infinity has been found
and not for lack of trying
mathematicians have tested by brute
force every single number up to 2 to the
68. that's 295 quintillion 147
quadrillion 905 trillion 179 billion 352
million 825
856 numbers
we know for certain that every single
one of those numbers eventually comes
back down to one
we have tested nearly 300 quintillion
numbers and none of them disproves the
conjecture in fact given this
information mathematicians calculate
that any loop other than 421 must be at
least 186 billion numbers long
so it seems pretty likely that the
conjecture is true
but this doesn't prove it
one way mathematicians have attempted to
prove it is by making a scatter plot
with all the seed numbers on the x-axis
and a number from each seed's sequence
on the y-axis now if you can show that
in every 3x plus 1 sequence there is a
number that is smaller than the original
seed well then you have proven the
call-outs conjecture because whatever
number you pick you know it will at some
point get smaller and that smaller
number as a seed also gets smaller and
so on down to one meaning the only way
any sequence can end is in the four to
one loop
this has not yet been shown but
in 1976 rijoteras was able to show that
almost all call-out sequences reach a
point below their initial value in 1979
this limit was reduced with almost all
numbers going to less than x to the
power of 0.869 and then in 1994 it was
further lowered to less than x to the
power of 0.7925
in this case the term almost all numbers
has a technical mathematical definition
it means that as the numbers you're
looking at go to infinity the fraction
that end up under the curve goes to one
then in 2019 one of the world's greatest
living mathematicians terry tau was able
to show 3x plus 1 obeys even stricter
criteria
he showed almost all numbers will end up
smaller than any arbitrary function f of
x so long as that function goes to
infinity as x goes to infinity
but the function can rise as slowly as
you like so
log x is an example or log log x works
too or log log log log x what this means
is for almost all numbers you can
guarantee that there is an arbitrarily
small number somewhere in its sequence
in a public talk he gave in 2020 terry
tau said this is about as close as one
can get to the call-outs conjecture
[Music]
mean everyone is trying to prove it true
which means almost no one is looking for
counter examples
it happened to me just uh two years ago
where there was a there was something i
was trying to prove that i was trying
for three years to prove
and i couldn't get it to work and then i
found a counter example and then i
realized what the correct statement
should have been and then a month later
i proved the correct statement maybe we
should be spending more energy looking
for counter examples than we're
currently spending i mean remember how
the number 27 grows all the way to 9232
here is a plot of seed numbers up to 10
000 with the largest number reached for
each seed plotted on the y-axis
the y-axis stops at a hundred thousand
but not all numbers can be shown at this
scale the seed
9663 for example climbs as high as 27
million
and as yet no one has proven why a
number couldn't just shoot off to
infinity
and it would take only one to disprove
the conjecture
or some set of numbers could be part of
a loop not connected to the main graph
as far as we know there is only one loop
for 2 one
but something strange happens if you
include negative numbers
applying the same three x plus one rules
as before there is not one loop not two
loops but three independent loops of
numbers and they start at low values
like minus 17 and minus five
why should there be disconnected loops
on the negative side of the number line
but not on the positive side
now one of the most convincing pieces of
evidence supporting the conjecture is
terry taus proof that almost all numbers
have a number in their sequence that is
arbitrarily small
but proving that almost all numbers obey
this criteria
isn't the same thing as proving that all
numbers do
how many numbers between one and a
hundred are perfect squares
the answer is ten
so ten percent of numbers up to a
hundred are perfect squares
how many numbers between one and a
thousand are perfect squares
the answer is thirty-one so only three
point one percent of the numbers up to a
thousand are perfect squares and the
higher you go the smaller this
percentage becomes such that in the
limit you could say almost all numbers
are not perfect squares the fraction of
numbers that are not perfect squares
goes to one as x goes to infinity
and yet we know there are an infinite
number of perfect squares and we know
exactly where they are
now we've tested by brute force all
numbers up to 2 to the 68 and they all
obey the callouts conjecture and you
might be thinking that well we should
have found a counter example by this
point
but on the scale of all numbers 2 to the
68 is nothing i mean the polya
conjecture proposed in 1919 by george
paulia asserted that the majority of
natural numbers up to any given number
have an odd number of prime factors the
conjecture was eventually proven false
by c brian hasselgrove in 1958 when he
identified a counterexample
what's remarkable is the value of this
counterexample was 1.845 times 10 to the
361. that's some 10 to the 340 times
bigger than all the numbers checked for
3x plus 1.
one way to think about 3x plus 1 is as
though it's a simple program run on a
touring machine the seed number is the
input to the machine
so in this picture 2 to the 68 is simply
an input tape 68 squares long you can
think of them as a string of ones and
zeros or black and white squares
saying the machine has transformed every
input up to this 68 square tape down to
1 should not give you a lot of
confidence that it will do so for all
inputs
in fact it's fairly simple to calculate
a number that shows any arbitrary
behavior you like so long as it is
finite if you want a number that
increases by three over two five
consecutive times you can calculate that
number if you want a number that climbs
by three over two ten times in a row or
a hundred times or a thousand times you
can easily calculate those numbers but
after the finite section you specify you
have no more control and every number
that has ever been tested always falls
to one if there is a counter example
it's virtually impossible that someone's
going to guess it
and the space of all possibilities is
too big to search exhaustively by brute
force two to the thousand is not a
searchable space
so if we're gonna find it we have to
find it by some intelligent process and
not by guess and check i had been on
team three x plus one for 20 years
and then
this point of view
i i i realized that like what do we
really know do we what
it's very hard to prove a theorem that's
false
and so could it be that everyone's
struggling to prove this thing because
it's not actually true
and 2 to the 60 is not a lot of evidence
and even the statistical version is
maybe true and
not evidence for the non-existence of a
divergent trajectory somewhere in the
three x plus one sequence
of course there is another option and
that is that we'll never know that the
problem is undecidable
in 1987 john conway created a
generalization of 3x plus one it was a
mathematical machine that he called
fractran
and he was able to show this machine is
touring complete which means it can do
anything a modern computer can do
but it also means that it's subject to
the halting problem a chance that the
machine never stops running and so
doesn't give you an output
and this does not prove that 3x plus 1
is also subject to the halting problem
but it is possible that given what we
know we may never prove the callouts
conjecture true or false
you're going to be taught in school that
we know a bunch of stuff and there it's
a little it's a lie
they're all lies here's this stupid
little problem
come on
really we can't solve this really
you know it just shows
that math is hard
if anything it shows that all the things
that we can solve are miracles
we have no right to have solutions to
all these other problems
for my whole life i've thought of
numbers as these incredibly regular
things full of patterns symmetry and
repetition
but what i'm realizing only now is just
how peculiar numbers really are you can
see this most clearly in the choral
representation from a simple
mathematical operation comes something
intricate organic looking and thus far
intractable to us
do all numbers connect to this structure
or is there some unique filament a
spindly little thread that doesn't
connect to any of this that runs off to
infinity and why is it so hard to tell
i think that's why paul erdosh said
mathematics is not yet ripe enough for
such questions
[Music]
what i love about 3x plus one is it's a
problem almost anyone can understand and
play around with and actually trying to
figure things out for yourself is the
best way to learn which is why i
subscribe to brilliant the sponsor of
this video now recently brilliant have
upped their interactivity for example
here is a great lesson on the
pythagorean theorem so you don't just
remember the formula but you really
understand what it means now brilliant
is a website and an app designed to get
you thinking deeply by engaging you in
problem solving it's one thing to read
through a textbook and think that you
get it but it's quite another to play
with interactives and actually test
yourself as you go and brilliant curates
the experiences so they get more and
more challenging over time there's
always a helpful tip or explanation that
takes your understanding to the next
level i'd highly recommend their course
on mathematical fundamentals which now
has even more interactivity and it has
topics that are relevant to all areas of
stem
and algorithm fundamentals for anyone
interested in coding
it's great to have a resource like this
to inspire you to learn something new
every single day i try to start off my
day by challenging myself with brilliant
and so if you'd like to join me and a
community of 8 million other learners go
to brilliant.org veritasium i will put
that link down in the description so i
want to thank brilliant for sponsoring
this video and i want to thank you for
watching